hey guys I'm Ryan right so right now
it's finally officially released the
comic-con trailer of The Suicide Squad
let's see what the new Joker voice is
gonna be there we go
beside four Killer Croc to enjoy
Courtney [ __ ] Jack Courtney [ __ ] Jai
Courtney which kidding Jai Courtney if
you're watching you're an [ __ ] let's
check on some work but I finally have
them the worst of the worst
looks like the Dodge
we're let's just say I put him in a hole
- away the hole there's rumors Amanda
that some of them have abilities oh yeah
I have seen things maybe Superman was
some kind of beacon for them to creep
back from the shadows want to assemble a
task force of the most dangerous people
on the planet who I think can do some
good they're bad guys exactly and if
anything goes wrong we blame them we
have built-in deniability what makes you
think you can control because getting
people to act against their own
self-interest is what I do follow
all you need to know is you work for me
with some kind of Suicide Squad
I'll save the world
Wow
Congress
hope you got insurance
now they say about the crazy ones huh Oh
oh yeah
I'm just gonna hurt you really really
like Jay Leno man why would a haunting
trailer ah I don't know ray didn't it is
but I really want it to be our Oh God I
want to watch it again again then we'll
talk about her a little bit more let's
go through this it's just the one
cinematography looks very similar to the
worst of the worst dark nights love that
that steak looks delicious by the way
let's just say I put them in a hole two
away the hole there's rumors Amanda that
some of them have abilities oh yeah
definitely looks really dark
maybe so it's very gritty there's a
menacing vibe of that ajay appreciating
because 1k are supposed to have silence
is the most dangerous people on the
planet who I think can do some good
they're bad guys exactly and if anything
goes wrong we blame them we have
built-in deniability
what makes you think you can control
because getting people to act against
them self-interest is what I do for
living love her she's so funky God likes
bread I don't know everyone in suicides
fall back I know most of the characters
looks so good the makeup on him looks
amazing
all you need to know is you work for me
definitely getting a lot of wealth Smith
oh that's it huh
we're the patsies with some kind of
Suicide Squad
that's what saved the world so Hollywood
gnarlie down for the whole euro ik
looking stuff
I get it but
and one of these guys is still feel like
that's a bad man on
now they say about the crazy ones huh
I'm liking it oh oh yeah oh I'm not
gonna kill you
I'm just gonna hurt you really really
really really I'm gonna work on that I'm
gonna get that down cuz everyone's gonna
be quoting this [ __ ] and I want to be
one of the people who gets that quote
right wow so much to talk about here
let's try to keep this short it does
kind of have that Nolan s five because
they're doing like the Man of Steel and
Batman vs Superman I thought it was
gonna have more of that kind of vibe I
see that like realistic nister going for
they're showing Will Smith's Deadshot a
lot more broad because he's [ __ ] you
know he's Will Smith that is the one
thing that's all about it's not
necessarily a big problem for me but it
is a feeling I don't want to leave the
theater feeling like I don't want to
feel like these guys are heroic they're
great human beings I love them you know
cuz it started showing like images of
like Will Smith hugging his daughter or
whoever that is I don't know you know
you're showing the emotional sides of
them which we will need because these
are the main characters so we're gonna
need to be emotionally invested in them
but by the end of this film I still want
to feel like these guys are [ __ ]
criminals you know after Jack Nicholson
after Heath Ledger Jared Leto had the
challenge of really having to provide
something different and even though we
only saw him briefly you can tell me
he's an amazing [ __ ] actor you can
tell that he is putting on a full
three-dimensional performance and this
is gonna be a different portrayal in Jai
Courtney the one line he had is Captain
Boomerang that was like you know what I
might give Jai Courtney a chance I'm
just sick of his American accent I just
don't think he is good at playing
American roles so maybe if he's playing
you know a little bit more European and
that would be good and David Ayer is a
great choice for this because he's done
a lot of like Grady gangster films and
that's what these guys complete you can
kind of utter like pretty much their
gang they're criminals and they're
coming together that's what gangsters
are I wish they didn't show Batman in
this I know there was like photos that
late but still it would have been nice
to be like I have a nice little surprise
when I watch the movie there's probably
gonna be a lot of speculation about who
Joker's talking to at the end
my theory is I remember in the trailer
briefly I would you know
I can grab a screenshot of it real fast
this looks like the Joker with purple
gloves putting his hands on Harley Quinn
I'm going to assume that that is a
transformation scene of when he's
turning Harley Quinn into you know
Harley Quinn if there's anyone that
could use an origin tale out of this
movie I think Harley Quinn is one for
sure you know like there's all talks
about are they gonna get their own
standalone movies how are they gonna
appear in the Batman films or other DC
films like flash and whatnot but I think
if anyone should get an origin tale in
this movie out of the main cast I would
like to see Harley Quinn's the most
anyway guys thanks for saying that was
out if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine and periscope because if we get
more followers we can get even more
product placement for things such as
quarks quarks are great
blah blah blah let's hop to the sex joke
if you take a court in a while it's in a
wine bottle and you're able to like you
know like get someone to pop it and just
shoots up your butthole oh yeah it might
cause some anal dysfunction might get
some rectal bleeding but in the end it
feels really good